- I don't like it.
- Try again.
I need to know why
you don't like it.
- The food is really important.
We really decided to do it
as a metaphor for what is
going on in each episode,
and also what the main characters
are feeling, and especially Sean.
- I mean, I literally
can't taste it.
- Okay, now you're being rude.
And we have guests.
- Food has to feed emotionally
into the characters,
and thematically
into the episode.
- He advises for some of
the best restaurants in the city.
- I, uh, feed butter and cream
to fat people.
- Sean is the kind of chef
that like to challenge you.
So whatever he finds,
he wants to cook.
- Strawberry?
- Lobster.
(spoon clatters)
- Julian.
- The foods a huge part,
and we're taking what
Anthony Basgallop has written,
and making sure that it's usable.
So it's nice.
It's a lot of life imitating art,
and a lot of very giving people
who are willing to learn
and willing to impart their knowledge
and what they've learned.
- Marc Vetri is one of
the great chefs in the world,
so we asked him would he want to
be the consultant on the show.
And we're so lucky to have him
and Chef Drew here
to be on set every day,
setting everything up,
you know, designing it,
talking us through everything.
Also, Toby, who plays Sean,
loves to cook. He's all in.
They're in the kitchen on the set,
which is a real kitchen,
and they're cooking stuff,
and so it makes it feel real
in every way because it is real.
- No, don't. I mean, she likes
the idea of spicy food,
but in reality,
it doesn't agree with her, so...
As long as she believes it's there,
she swears she can taste it.
- Really, when you get into food,
and you talk to a lot of chefs,
and you're dealing with that,
they see it as life-giving.
That's how it's been threaded
through the show.
That the food, yes,
is extravagant and over the top,
and kind of
a little overbearing,
but in the end, really,
is life-giving.
- The trout is delicious.
- I love precision of food, and I do find
the great chefs super-inspiring to me.
I'm inspired by how they're driven,
the precision of it,
the discipline involved and the craft.
I try to bring that here.